what's up everyone here at gamespot
playing the opening day of the call of
duty black ops 3 beta on xbox one i'm
mike maherty here with eric tay what up
eric you played a lot of this game on
ps4 so far we did do that i did too much
probably but they kept kind of unlocking
like more levels and more specialists as
like the beta kept going was like oh no
we're just gonna add another day yeah
we're gonna add another day and so we
kept grinding it out so this is like a
new we got a newer account here so it's
like rob's newer account so we're gonna
be
playing through this and leveling it up
um and if you guys of course have
questions we will be in the chat to uh
try to answer them to the best of our
ability
we are also streaming today on uh
youtube gaming for the first time so if
you haven't already starred or followed
that channel you might want to hit that
um so you know when we go live on there
as well but uh you're going to play
someone other than profit here or yeah
i'd rather right now i'll just play
profit
that's uh rob set this up rob loves him
some glitching but for those who don't
know who haven't been paying attention
to the ps4 beta or we're kind of waiting
for this pretty much black ops 3's new
thing with multiplayer specialists and
you pick a character they have
one weapon one ability and they kind of
are like you know supers and destiny
just like kind of super powered um
overpowered you know whether it's one
hit kills or
with the one i'm using is glitch it
essentially i will press it and i'll
warp back about
three seconds to where i was before
sometimes i feel like it's longer but i
can't tell i haven't used it enough so
if that's kind of what um
is your feeling then we'll go with that
i will say too it's like
it is at least a little fair in the
sense that even if you do glitch you do
still have retain the damage yeah it's
just that if you might teleport pretty
far away so like they probably won't be
able to kill you um but
you guys will see it here in a second
yeah so
there are how many maps in the beta they
released the fourth one for ps4 if i
recall correctly
either way this is one of them obviously
yeah they uh they added one at the end
of the playstation one i'm kind of
curious if it's in here yet i didn't see
uplink earlier so it might not be might
be like kind of that same process of
like play it for a bit we'll add you
know more levels and add another map
um but yeah
you're gonna see us on a lot of the same
a couple similar maps here
yeah
and uh oh okay
playing destiny a lot lately and the um
time to kill on this is vastly different
vastly
i'll probably hand this over to eric
sometimes soon he's been playing a lot
more
setting me up to fail yeah or i'll just
try to get as much nice as possible we
can do that
be more fun to watch you than me um
beats 85 asking you know upon our first
impressions of the game is this anything
like advanced warfare i'll let you go
first so from my take on it it's yeah
not a ton but or yeah so the traversal
is pretty similar it's not as shifty or
i think chris waters said it was more
staccato movement with advanced warfare
where you kind of dodging side to side
using thrusters but it's still you know
i can show the wall run which is pretty
self-explanatory you have the dash or
the power slide kind of thing which is
useful for escaping certain situations
in terms of traversal yeah advanced
warfare kind of influenced this
definitely this is a little slower
in my experience
um
but advanced warfare itself was very
much you know vertical maps and kind of
getting above people or below in certain
positions but there's the wall run
which i don't really use too much
from what i've played
i've kind of get shot every time i
attempt a wall run
yeah i mean it's something you get used
to but you know as you play and as you
learn the maps a little bit more uh
there's all these different spots that
you start to realize like oh yeah like
that seems like a good spot to you know
maybe flank someone um i personally will
say kind of i
kind of feel the same way you do in the
sense that you know it is similar in
some ways to advanced warfare but a
little bit more toned down i think yeah
more black ops style
which is good yeah i like the black ops
series a lot so yeah i think the biggest
change though in in black ops 3 compared
to advanced warfare is just having all
the specialists and their abilities and
kind of
um each each specialist as we talked
about has two you know very unique
abilities that oh watch this so okay
that's the downside right that's the
downside of wall running once you kind
of commit to it if you're over a gap
especially on this map with those
bottomless pits but you can you can ads
while you're wall running though so it's
not like the worst thing it's just you
have to be looking whoa yeah glitch back
to that wall run no
see that i had no idea where i would end
up with that so that's the cool thing
too though right with glitch is that one
time
i was about to fall off the the map but
i i glitched back to safety but that
obviously is not how you always want to
use it so i'm hoping i can get a good
glitch in here because
there are times when i'll sprint down
off a roof and come right into someone's
face then glitch back and be like 10
feet back behind them and it's pretty
great when you pull it off rob handler
he's really good at it he's been using
it a lot i think that's why it's the
first one he unlocked
um
nice
yeah the enraged armadillo on the
youtube chat makes a good point you
can't really like
side boost anymore right so that's good
it's not just
like that kind of uh rocket reversal at
all times it's just kind of you know
covering distance rather than actually
doing those dodges but but you can't do
a side like
dash though in a way like on the ground
like where like if you're running you
can actually like
boost to your right or your left though
and like on a slide yeah oh yeah yeah
you can slide like right or left like an
extreme way like with
like with the boost and whatnot right
but yeah other than that it's definitely
got its own distinct feel from advanced
warfare you know i mean different
developer making it but you know
advanced warfare definitely seems to
have left its mark on the series as of
yeah the last few years uh question
about customization i would say
customization is kind of like a black
ops two-ish in a way where you have kind
of like a similar pick tennis system
it's not necessarily pick 10 but you get
to kind of pick your loadout if you want
to load up on your primary weapon you
can do that with like primary gunfighter
you can like double up on your perks but
you do have a limited amount of uh that
you can do
and then like it'll tell you like you
don't have any more slots i think it
actually might still be 10. i think it
is yeah you know certain guns take out
more than one certain items but um
so right there that would have actually
been a good time to use glitch because
but i just kind of forget i had it um
glitch is one of those you have to
really get used to just activating when
you're in a certain situation like
got the final kill there we go right you
warmed up yeah it's all coming back to
you switching over from the ps4
controller is always weird it's crazy
that you only got 250 points though for
that like i remember on playstation
every time we won it was like over a
thousand but maybe it was because it was
kill confirm or something yeah i don't
know i don't know oh yeah i think he'll
confirm it's worth a little more because
you get less
um
kills and kill confirmed that's uh i
would assume
yeah majority of the time
so that's this uh outrider class that if
you saw
she was the character with the bow and
arrow which
you can just shoot really fast and then
it'll explode on after impact or you can
charge it up and it'll kill them
automatically kind of launch them and
then explode yeah you can also just
feather it if they're like really close
it actually is like pretty generous if
you're almost next to them you can
almost like flick it i know just like
land on them and i don't think it'll
kill you even if you're right next to
them but yeah
i don't have
the um
to upgrade token to try another
specialist out but i can i'll try it
using the smg next time what else did i
unlock for what did you spend didn't you
have two tokens just now mm-hmm are you
guys
got another smg just to try to show some
different weapons nice
what other attachment oh the quick draw
nice i like the metalwork use it a lot
uh yeah i used to like it a lot and then
for some reason as i played more and
more
um i started using the ark and the hbx a
lot more yeah i think it's just because
rate of fire even though the mana war
has more damage it shoots slower and so
i would get in these
short to mid-range fights where we kind
of come up on each other and like just
having the higher rate of fire would
usually win me the fight yeah because
you know getting shot you just kind of
like start to stagger a little bit but
yeah yeah so everybody here as of now is
the first four specialists that are
already unlocked before you hit whatever
level obviously because the beta i just
launched today there's gonna be a lot of
those people
but yeah so you see profit is who i'm
being with glitch you uh he also has the
tempest that's like an arc lightning gun
you electrify someone that jumps to
other people nearby it's actually the
range on it's pretty insane like you
would think when you visually look at it
it's like okay i just need to not touch
the electricity that's on the ground
because like there's like a little bit
left over from the person that gets hit
by it but it's like it jumps yeah so
like i tried jumping away from one like
in the air like pretty i was pretty high
up in the air and it's still kind of
like like the game i guess instinctively
knew i was next to them so then just
like shot on over to me yeah so
sometimes you'll see like that crazy
like triple or quad kill just because
everyone's kind of bunched up and just
starts bouncing everywhere right yeah
it's
i mean that's like it's worth knowing
the specialist classes not just for
yourself offensively but just so you
kind of know how to
escape them or counter them with glitch
you kind of once you see it you'll know
when they're doing it and kind of react
to that and look behind them and this
isn't the best spot for me right now but
glitch is actually pretty useful on this
map because you can kind of go back
outside if things go wrong in here yeah
i'm being asked if we feel that the
power like having the powers of the
specials are uh overpowered
um i mean they are but everybody gets
yeah exactly so i was to your point it's
kind of even i thought i killed it like
an equal playing field but
for the most part i won't say that also
i feel like some specials are clearly
better than others in my opinion but
yeah um everyone does have
you know their own abilities and i would
say like some counter other ones and and
whatnot um glitch is really strong
uh previously i i made the comment that
it was a very defensive kind of cooldown
but it's it can be used either way you
can like totally run in
uh try to assess the situation sometimes
you're like there's too many people like
they're probably gonna use that because
she got the jump on me yeah so
uh i don't think they're too overpowered
they're fun and they can seem
overpowered though i can see why you
would feel that way in the beginning
when you start playing because like
someone might just get it really fast
and like wreck you with it but i think
for the most part they're pretty pretty
balanced so aside from glitch what are
some that you think are kind of
overpowered um
try glitch i really like
uh so reaper who's at level 34 i don't
think his special is necessarily
overpowered but it's like kind of it's
pretty fun to use and it's going to
annoy a lot of people what he does is
he sends out three clones of himself and
basically they look like you right and
you're running around so what will
happen is people will try to shoot the
clones you won't take damage and then
you'll see that they're totally facing
the wrong way and then oh nice glitch so
there's that so i didn't die but i
didn't really miss
my other if my other guy had oh that
never mind okay so it did work i didn't
get the assist but at least i we i
survived and
we killed the other one yeah it's all
that's what it's also good oh geez um
that's what it's also good for is
if you can glitch out of there they'll
kind of be focused on you and then your
teammate can kill them which i've been
on the killing side of that before
yeah i really like a war fighter the
what's the specialist who uses the
warfighter grenade launcher do you
remember tay
sorry uh
the specialist that does what sorry you
has the warfighter grenade launcher
oh battery right yeah yeah yeah i like
that it's kind of
i mean it's crazy pretty easy to use but
then if you if you hit them it's a
one-hit kill but then if you miss it
like does a cluster bomb it's like three
so it lobs three grenades
uh if you're right next to the person
basically it just instagives them and
they turn into like giblets um but if
like you said if you shoot them what
they do is like it bounces with three
grenades and then if you get hit by it
you die and i think you get eight rounds
of that
um
or the the duration of the the special
right and some specials will come up
faster than others i think
like glitch comes up faster than tempest
or at least it feels that way which is
definitely i mean even more than like
sparrow the longbow yeah so i think the
weapon ones are a little slower than
like
the uh like ability ones so like
glitches and ability uh the outlander
has her vision pulse which kind of gives
her like that x-ray vision for like a
short
short period of time which i really like
but i think it's more useful for
hardcore modes
yeah i'm sure like that's the other
thing is that
you know in the early parts of the beta
a lot of people are playing
you know tdm or maybe kill confirmed and
so some of these abilities might not
shine as much as if you're playing like
you said hardcore
or like hardpoint like some some of
these abilities you can really see will
shine more in certain game modes like
overdrive for roon which is like the run
faster one uh he sorry he runs faster
when he uses it that was sparrow yeah
yeah that or that was outlander using
the sparrow but uh ruins overcharge
would be really good for like something
like uplink
you can grab the ball and then use over
overdrive or i think it's overdriver
overcharge
to run faster and like cap the point
with the ball
yeah so there's a lot of emerging
gameplay that comes out of combining
things especially the specialists kind
of influence how you create your class
with what weapons like so glitch goes
well with shotguns because
i mean if you're in interiors and
indoors and stuff you can kind of get
the close range attack
with the shotguns but at the same time
glitch you can go back into other rooms
so that was a sweet glitch all right so
that's kind of
my favorite time using glitches when you
get uh you can kind of see them still
looking for you but yeah disorient them
after a while everybody starts to know
what glitch does and then they'll kind
of turn around but that guy's i mean
yeah it confuses people still but yeah
as you play you're gonna start seeing
more and more uses that's like one of
them uh like i said you can use it to
like kind of
sometimes get you out of really bad
situations where you run ahead you see
three people are like okay i'm not gonna
win that back you know back out yeah uh
which i'm the kind of player if i see
like two if i see two people i kind of
never try to do that unless i clearly
have the drop on them but so that's why
glitches i like glitch a lot
then you got the underwater stuff right
here i don't know where that guy went
just now
yeah it's near you can shoot underwater
and fight underwater which is odd but
whatever it's still what's weird to me
actually is
so
the 34 special the level 34 specialist
is a reaper and he's a robot essentially
right but for whatever reason i still
can get damage underwater when you know
clearly i'm a robot
and i shouldn't have any breathing
problems but you know
is it constant damage i never really
paid attention all right so here's going
to be a glitch
uh that was actually kind of huh i guess
it set me up for this person that just
came through here
nevermind uh someone's saying rejac is
op as
f reject is a skill for the level 28
specialist nomad basically after you die
you can come back to life i don't think
it's actually too overpowered because
when i was fighting it
it leaves this green fog right where you
died and if the green fog is there you
pretty much know that the nomad is going
to come back to life so you can
basically wait for him to get up almost
uh and kill him again
yeah but and yeah in the meantime his
teammates can kind of help him out maybe
yeah potentially right
but yeah but like you said you start
to
recognize telltale signs of certain
abilities and yeah when they're being
used against you and whatnot
so that was a useful wall run i guess
one of the few i've pulled off
okay so here's glitch again see if i can
i saw him but
i don't really use submachine guns much
but
i think we also had a question about um
the maps how we how we like the maps in
relation to like black ops maps um
i like these maps actually uh this one
especially i usually
like uh this is one of the bigger ones
yeah so in the beta this is one of the
larger ones i don't think i played that
newer one they released but you did
right yeah the snow one's interesting um
i like i i for oh you got it again nice
uh i like
the new one it's it's like you know you
got to have a snow level in call of duty
right so there's like a building there's
like a little side factory
i mean
it's very call of duty right there's a
lot of
kind of like narrow paths that you're
going to end up having a lot of fire
fights
sprinkled in with some
some new traversal type you know like
you can wall run the building to get to
like a different part of the snow so
it's good i mean i i still think
like you this is one of the better maps
just in terms of like
it's like kind of bigger wider there's
more places to go yeah i guess that you
don't necessarily always have to just
like fight someone right um
but you know that's what cod is right
yeah yeah
a lot of moment-to-moment action what is
that like building in the desert kind of
with those three long sight lines uh
because that one's definitely high back
it's i think it's combined is it combine
or was that combined i'm gonna shut it
back out quick and might have been
hunting do get another specialist going
yeah sure take it do i need to i think
it's combined though so do we have any
should i back out or just stay in the
lobby you can stay in the lobby we have
any
requests um
that we wanted to see i don't think so
so this is kind of like he's got this
jumping ability ruin um this is the
longbow
which is pretty cool this is vision
pulse which i like but it doesn't last
very long i like the if you're gonna buy
one oh you got battery actually i could
yeah so yeah uh she's all right i
actually like um
outlander more i think the next sketch
of the bow then yeah sure the next
specialist that we would unlock
is that 22
okay and
um
she has the annihilator which is kind of
like the golden gun in destiny you get a
magnum it's like that's probably my
favorite
but i also like
hunters a lot in destiny it's like a six
shot hand cannon that's a one shot
pretty much
it doesn't look like we haven't seen
anyone that's unlocked that class yet
yeah well it did come out like you said
today yeah right
okay so what is this shotgun right here
see that outrider i keep calling her the
outline i could try sniping i guess
uh is it the lotus because man the the
dragon
is pretty good
or not yeah it's a bolt-action one the
the dragon which is the second sniper
it's like way easier to use because it's
semi-fire and you have 20 bullets okay
and like
yeah
okay or maybe you're just a sniper
after all i what was the so modern
warfare 2 i think is the most i played
of any call of duty game
and it had that one
it was one of the earlier snipers but it
was the bolt action and
oh the
defender maybe i think it was the
defender okay or avenger i don't know
something really cool i can't remember
this but it was bolt action i always
loved it
so this is the map i was just talking
about it's kind of got these three long
sight lines in this middle room which i
try not to go in but see if i can
we'll all run
so right there people always kill me and
i'm jumping i don't know why
granada how did that
it's like he oh he could see your i
think like a tag as you're running
potentially
so yeah i'll get the sparrow longbow at
some point and then use oh okay it was
called the intervention yeah
intervention thank you thank you chad i
knew it was something yeah
but yeah i like that sniper rifle a lot
it was bolt action but
nice
oh [ __ ]
yeah the pistols are pretty good uh you
have the semi-fire one there's also a
burst fire one yeah the burst forward
like a lot
the rf
five
oh get rid of that whoops
it's okay there's no friendly fire it's
casual
jesus needs spams oh i jumped still in
testing
yeah
oop oh i was boxed in
um i'm going to switch off the sniper
rifle do it
kind of try a shotgun this isn't the
best map
but the next one yeah it's not the best
map first uh some people can snipe on
this map
um
i think the multiplayer is pretty easy
to pick up you might get frustrated in
the beginning i i was because i just
wasn't used to playing cod after playing
so much like destiny and
you know counter-strike and stuff like
that it's you kind of forget this the
pace of which call of duty games work
yeah but once you kind of get back into
and you start playing it you're like
okay yeah like
it's kind of like riding a bike again
um
yeah it's accessible and
i'm actually with mike mchardy today for
the some of the folks that don't know uh
he's one of our new game spot editors
just started oh he got a double with his
uh gravity spikes which that's like sort
of a [ __ ] titan smash yeah
i still oh man
wow there's just oh so that was was that
the spirit i did no he did it again
or another ruin in his gravity spikes
yeah i just started like a month or so
ago
i think call of duty oh here's
oh that's not
i am reading the comments in chat from
all three or i'm trying my best to do
all three so if you guys have questions
or anything that we can try to answer i
will try to do that
and i'll hand the controller over to
eric after this
all right so you can start reading the
chat yeah yeah um so i've got the spare
i'm gonna pull that out so this is the
longbow
uh we did answer this a little bit
earlier but again people asking how it
compares to aw or advanced warfare and
it's like i think we both agree it's
kind of like a toned-down version that's
more black opsy that's the short answer
to that so yeah which is a good thing
oh
okay you didn't get to see that but
yeah so this oh nice oh
we got saved
yeah but that that corridor there has a
lot of opportunity for like wall running
stuff i don't know you still i still
have to get used to it
sometimes you make like a really sick
play and you're like yeah yeah while
running and then but then half or more
than half of the time you're like whoa
oh i got picked off on the wall it'll
feel really cool but until you're just
dropping
and then everybody else sees you like
that one in the middle like where you're
at that ramp where you can run into the
middle of the map i'm like everyone that
ever runs on that map is a free kill
yeah because
there's never like that right there that
person that tried to go over he probably
got killed right away
probably
do you like this smg the weevil i'm not
really not a big fan of it no i i
usually i used to like the p90 a lot
when i it looked like that
oh
how did that not kill
no
oh i do know why it's because uh that
that thing has a three damage it's like
real low
yeah i
kind of just
these suits oh man that's another case
of destiny i tried to knife them with rv
uh the
the the supers you do lose if you uh die
with it
so
the only instance where you might get
saved is like sometimes if you're
popping you're
um
and you die as you're like trying to use
it you won't lose it or you'll lose some
of it instead of all of it right um but
if it comes like if your bow is out and
you die the moment your bow is out
you're like you're pretty much f then
you'll lose your super yeah like you
might even have seven shots left in your
bow and you die you're still gonna lose
it and on the other side of that if you
do kill someone while they have their
super active you get you know bonus
points
as much as the points contribute to it i
mean toward your score streak um
not a good kd there you wanna take over
all right i'll take over the chat and
eric can
i'm gonna stick it up some more points
it's always weird uh going to like an
xbox after playing playstation
playstation because i'm so used to like
the dual sticks being at like the middle
part of the controller yeah
which i think you can change with the
elite controller but i don't know if i'm
going to spend like 100 or 150 bucks on
a controller
all right i need to make a class here
man so bare bones rob what are you doing
setting this up to oh so this this gun i
like a lot yeah
how close are we ranking up again
decent probably decent because we're
like low level like every time
like you level your guns and stuff like
that you'll get a pretty uh good amount
of
experience as well so
oops
you level up decently fast
see if i can do all right oh we're going
to the big map
hunted
bought a sparrow
yeah i think that's the first one i use
the longbow seems pretty appealing to me
yeah everyone wants to shoot those
explosive arrows yeah
until they figure out glitch and then
all you're gonna see is
people glitching everywhere
spectre was fun but
his
special abilities didn't seem as crazy
spector was like the level 40 uh
specialist and
he has a short-term camo cloak
skill
and then his second ability is called
ripper where
he basically gets like two
i wouldn't call them psionic blades but
like two laser blades that like if you
lock on it'll uh
it'll um
like thrust that like almost like
commando knife from old mw
like that's how far it would go but you
have to lock onto them you can't just
like walk up and then like
it won't just auto lunge oh why are you
just kind of hiding back there you got
two of us sitting in that corner i feel
bad
so for those wondering how to get beta
codes it's the same as ps4 right if you
pre-order the game yep you have access
in right away yep so if you want to play
this you can just go pre-order
black ops 3 right now and get in and
kill tay
yep you can come try to kill us
probably will too
i was just gonna say this isn't the
razorback this is the ak yeah are we
universal we didn't have a token oh
right
the razorback so i'll just use
the standard assault rifle which i
actually like oh let's steal his arc
seven because it's like way better than
ours that's what you do too day one call
of duty if someone if people are ahead
of you you just start taking their guns
and just own them with their guns i
always feel like i'm exposing myself and
i take time to pick up another gun i
know it's pretty quick but
yeah i don't know you get caught
sometimes like i probably pretty much
got caught there for picking it up
yeah so see the uh
you need to actually equip the combat
knife perk right now it's just the
yeah you got to buy this way
two of them nice nice job thanks that
would have been a good case for glitch
but you handled it well and i mean you
don't have equilibrium but usually when
i see two one like okay i'm gonna
get out of here i think there's a guy
behind me so that worked out
but yeah that's a good point to make
though is a melee in the front is two
hits now but in the back it's a it is a
one shot if you're behind them
oh were you just like hanging out here
just like so there's a razorback you can
pick up
oh that's a good air okay though hold on
let's all right there you go
that guy just die
oh
no
okay somebody's got sparrow or what's
gonna call it yeah you've got a sparrow
out
which i'll try to do too but oh
crap
i tend to like using it to try to get
multiple kills yeah but that's just the
dream obviously when it works well you
can launch them into a group of people
i've done it once
it works a little better when you're
playing like domination or something
yeah
all right here we'll try it
oh
so there i lost the bow
there you go that sucks
and i just got hit by it so there that's
what it would have been like if i had
not been a scrub
yeah it's really satisfying to get it
it's kind of a smaller
reticle but it's you can feather it
really fast
there are places to come there are
directions you can come
from for pretty much every part of these
maps
you get the triple i was trying to i
think i'm going to die trying to get the
triple oh there's a
oh he's got the double
yeah almost choked on that team
no
why did i challenge him like that i had
a stun grenade
oh crap you're behind us
so they plan to do the same thing with
xbox one uh release that fourth map
about a few days in starting to feel
like they will but who knows right yeah
so i assume but i don't know for sure
[ __ ]
dude they're behind us again i love
those call of duty spawns
yeah they switch pretty frequently
oh i'm terrible
surprised she wasn't kind of waiting for
you yeah she i think she was chasing
someone else yeah
no the uav and sparrow yep i'm gonna do
that now
it's a good call
hopefully they're still on the bridge
and then i can uh
get something oh [ __ ] i just ran by
someone
where is this dude
jesus
that wasn't panic jumping at all
oh man
so do you have a favorite overall do you
say uh
you like glitch a lot
oh there you go
sorry i shouldn't be asking questions oh
he got you with one
sorry i got i got the mini triple there
we got the mini triple that's what
matters
uh sorry what was your question so did
you say you have a favorite overall
um um i like reaper a lot which is the
level 34 yeah guy uh he looks like a
robot
it's even he's one of the self
resurrects uh no he's the one that
creates clones or has the chain gun um
but he's fun i just like his aesthetic
even when he runs it just like you hear
like the footsteps of like a cyborg kind
of guy he does look really cool too
what happens when we run on walls kids
here i'll just run on that wall this
this spot's actually pretty good though
if you if like some of the people on
stream haven't watched it like you can
go this way yeah and then go around all
the way around good for avoiding the
firefights and inevitably break out on
that bridge and then you can try to
flank like the team when they spawn like
by going on this rock which i guess you
can run on and then uh too bad they're
not spawning like
that they might be but
i think they're on the other side of the
map
yeah they're across the bridge
or at least coming this way yeah
oh is that guy just chilling in the
water
oh no they're coming for me
the camp prone didn't work
usually it's a fail-safe move
believe it or not it did not yeah i
rarely go
prone in multiplayer really
i still see people do the like the like
the semi-dolphy dolphin dive it's not
really again dolphin dive anymore
because you can't you'll just power
slide now but
oh where'd that guy go
got him man we're just getting these uh
final kill finishing it off they're
setting us up actually no you did you
did pretty well that match did i i don't
know it felt like a one to one or one kd
kind of game maybe that
no i'd say you're 1.17 all right see how
close i am
it's probably pretty close
all right number one on the team though
wait for it
2.5 wow i sold myself short yeah you did
all right i
sold you short too i bought you short
yeah
it's all right that's what day one's
about yeah these guys haven't played
playstation so they don't know
have there been any other questions
yet
do you have questions anyone
feel free to leave them on twitch or you
got a token
uh token does anybody have suggestions
or do we just want to do a new
specialist and show them that we could
do that too we just so we did sparrow
and
glitch
um i'm trying to think of other ones i
like war machine but then there's only
four right
that we can pick from right now right
now until yeah
14 or something
22 22. yeah
so there's battery we have profit with
the tempest gun there's
gravity spikes it's always entertaining
i guess
i hate like i hate how you can really
only get one maybe two and if you're
really extremely lucky you get three
because
it just feels so limited like you get
eight rounds of grenades you get six or
seven lightning shots you get seven
outlander
bone air like explosive bow or
arrow sorry
and then i think serif has like six in
her annihilator so yeah
and i really like the vision pulse but
that
again it only lasts for like two seconds
i've seen people use it pretty good
though like because it's one of the
those things where you might have it
before you get uav
and so you can tell if anyone's near you
all right people are asking how does it
feel to play does it feel like a
call of duty game in general like i mean
people were asking this earlier but
you're saying it's kind of you know
black ops combined with advanced warfare
but
definitely not as shifty as advanced
warfare
um
yeah smoother i think
not necessarily like in a better way but
just feels
smoother and like more fluid i guess
whereas warfare is like kind of darting
side to side and jumping and i agree
with you on those points
oh all right
uh i mean yeah the only thing you have
to get used to is like wall running or
potentially power sliding or something
like that like you can use those things
effectively uh you do have a gauge in
the middle of the screen that pops up
every time you use your
um abilities and whatnot that
uh
like oh [ __ ] i didn't do it there i
didn't have enough momentum but is that
a suppressor yeah
i saw someone but uh you can you'll
know when you're like out of like boost
and stuff like this so like if i use
this once it's like it's starting to use
the meter
that could have looked a lot cooler [ __ ]
that up oops i mean i screwed that up
part of my language
yeah for people asking this is the xbox
one beta ps4 beta um
it ended
uh last sunday monday monday that was
monday monday
we did leveling on
on monday right yeah we came in that was
the first thing you were doing as per
the week before that
but yeah this is xbox one and it's
if you pre-ordered it it you can play
whenever yep it's live today it's live
until
same thing like 30th right yeah four
days
uh i think it's out on pc as well so
okay and pc players you pre-order on
that come on there we go
yeah
oh
oh he just got killed too that's fine
not fast enough the stream got to see at
least uh a freebie double
oh here this this spot's kind of dirty
if no one
nice
and they keep running at you yep
oh there's a grenade
oh whatever it's fine but yeah you can
do that on that spot i
have a combat knife guy so if you can
see the sparrows range is pretty great
um
if you can see them it doesn't have the
best zoom it's just more like an aim
down the sight kind of thing but it's
got decent assist though yeah
[ __ ] that might come from behind
and then if you kind of just run into
someone you could feather it you don't
like that yeah
thanks game i feel like every time you
get the sparrow out someone else gets it
out and kills you
very soon after
i mean that's the dream right there is
like a choke point where you can kind of
just
unleash it
did you get that guy
so after playing until level what 40 on
the ps4
do you feel that black ops that the
specialist class is enough to keep you
hooked past that do you still want to
keep playing and everything is it enough
to keep it fresh game to game
ah sort of
yeah i i
like most people probably that play call
of duty oh fudge uh
mainly play because like your friends
are playing it you know and so that's
probably what's gonna
decide how much i play this game it's
like if they get into it i'll get into
it
um
i think it's fun for a while i like i
would keep playing to get i probably
would have played at least 50 to get the
the next specialist so that i could at
least see what they did what their
abilities are and see if i like it
i know that when i first got reaper i
was having a lot of fun because i really
enjoyed playing him so i would say for
anyone else that's you know considering
playing it or buying or whatever i think
if you can find a specialist that you
really like it might enhance the game
for you yeah but then if they don't feel
that special to you then it's probably
going to just be like call of duty for
you yeah
what about you from the like the amount
of time you played uh yeah i want to
play more i didn't play as much as you
guys i played until level
20 or so um
i really
i like how the specialists
i think i learned every specialist after
once i got to level 10 or so
i didn't master them but i knew what to
do with each of them that i had unlocked
at that point um
it's just i like how the specialist
affects how i look at my class loadouts
especially like when i'm playing game
modes i had one game
sorry one
specialist that was this
pulse vision the outrider's pulse vision
so this specialist but the other ability
not the longbow
i had pulse vision equipped for hardcore
hardcore mode i had you know anti-uav i
had
just suppressors on both weapons
so
i like how that kind of influenced how i
was creating my class and how also
just totally separate game modes can
cater to different class types obviously
team deathmatch you can be whatever you
want to be but
um i probably wouldn't use war machine
on hard um you know hardcore just
because
you're already doing more damage it's
not the best in terms of stealth
i prefer to play stealthy and try to
stay off other people's radars
so there's a lot to think about in
addition to just the regular create a
class pick 10 system which i like yeah
um
again i haven't played the level 40 like
you have but
i don't know
i think a lot of it too though that's
going to be harder to judge
just during this beta for most people is
that
to your point
uh you know the specialists are going to
play a little bit differently depending
on you know what type of uh game type
you play on yeah but predominantly what
we were seeing at least our playstation
was that
you know
uh
day one day two a lot of team death
match you know maybe so i i started
getting into kill confirmed games like
on a more regular basis later out down
the road so it's gonna be interesting to
see how much of the other game types
people will be able to play like you
know the dominations
hardpoint i think eventually they added
uplink so if you guys have a different
game type it might be harder to
just get into it yeah
but yeah
so that's the most appealing thing to me
is a kind of emergent
who do you gamepl ruin or
battery
her armor thing is not the greatest to
be honest
i'll say war machine all right let's try
war machine oh just sure everyone i like
using it um
she also just seems badass when they're
showing her
when they're showing your
party in the game lined up is she this
intense gaze that looks almost like
she's
she's got a thousand-yard stare i'd say
but it's also kind of terrifying
especially because you have a giant
grenade launcher draped over her
shoulder
i'm really digging those kind of
character or sorry specialist
kind of just loading screens you
whichever one you pick will show up on
your like main loading screen and also
in the multiplayer screen and you know
depending on
uh which ability you picked like they
might do different things yeah so like
with spectre i had the ripper
and
you know he would he like you know
popped out the blades and it was kind of
like waving them around a little bit
yeah just like something that like
visually appealing to look at during the
loading screen which is cool
so we're back on hunted yep
the big map go here and hope that
they're not sniping
or
hope they're sniping and kill them yeah
that also works i'm okay with that
i don't go up there often because
everyone can see you
this spot is like pretty good oh
she's like that little bat back swim
on the back just one hand
one-handed
use the assault rifle on me no problem
the most leisurely kill i've ever
seen that's that's pretty annoying
actually i don't know if you've
experienced that oh gosh get through
easily
no no no thanks a lot uh no where you're
kind of like running through like a
corridor or a hallway or a door or
something and someone else is there and
you just get you guys can't run past
each other yeah
those asking the beta is not available
for ps4 anymore
it is
done for as of
now at least i don't think they have
plans to bring it back out before the
game comes out in what like
two two months i think two months
nope forget what
what month it is
almost september
september it's november right
yeah usually
um
but yeah so i'm i'm eager to see what
they do the campaign because i've always
actually enjoyed the black ops campaigns
they've always got kind of a
crazy story compared to others
advanced warfare i thought did a decent
job but
i've always just thought treyarch kind
of had the narrative down and there's
gonna be zombies again yeah they're
doing that weird um what's like the
aesthetic they're going with it's that
old uh old-timey yeah i wouldn't say
roaring 20s kind of thing not really
yeah
so should be interesting and they're
going to have like
some
big name actors and stuff like that
which they kind of did with um
advanced warfare a little bit right with
their zombies but you know treyarch's
the one that really
forged the way with the call of duty
zombies so anyone that likes zombies
will probably be totally into that
yeah oh
that guy is dead
oh he looks like i saw me on uav or
something
oh i saw you come back in what was the
point of that i don't know really count
oh he's running from
that guy
all right i got the war machine
oh there's a sparrow behind me though
yeah hit markers for days
don't kill me
so there is another change that could
affect multiplayer later on in certain
game modes like competitive game modes
before the match starts you can
either you can um
vote like veto an ability
or a specialist class
or you can oh yeah the plane bans yeah
so you can pick one that will stay safe
and you can use it for the match or if
there's someone on the other team that's
been doing really well with glitch set
you can ban glitch and it will not be in
the match
but then yeah once you pick something i
think you're the only one that's going
to have it so it's going to be a lot
more varied as far as there won't be
four war machines so that was the war
machine grenade launcher which i like
and then we just and someone just killed
you with one frag grenade
triple
so yeah it'll be more like
this one person will have war machine or
this one person will be using gravity
spikes so it'll be a much more
multi-fairies match i guess as far as
not everyone using a longbow
and we've actually made pretty decent
progress with ranking up in this in the
last hour yeah we got he was like what
three or four when we started he's
already like seven so
it's like old cod where it gets uh it
ramps up in terms of how much experience
you're gonna need
oh crap
stole that kill probably sorry guys
oh close it looks like
oh he had the same idea
damn it's like when you're kind of
walking towards someone in the street
and you're walking right at each other
then you sidestep to the same side and
then reacting to that you do the same
thing yeah
this happens that happens to me a lot in
this side we'll go to flank someone then
turns out they were thinking the same
exact thing
oh there are a lot of people there all
right
playing bad now
can't keep up the
the dream the dream runs that we're
having
hopefully get the war machine at least
one more time though before this ends
that's the goal
oh
another guy right there
oh crap i just picked up a razorback
that's fine there you go oh two
oh there we go
so bad time for a few war machines
probably
nice
she's like you got that gun down
yeah i like the razor back a lot it's my
smg of choice it has like razorback no i
picked that oh god it has like very
little recoil and actually can
hit like
mid-range like pretty well
it's like one behind us but like the
rest are in front of us
nope
wow was that the shotgun that was it was
oh my god that was so far
it was like
matador 64. um which someone got today
but anyway
nice
so then you can see when he doesn't hit
someone directly it just
splits into five or six grenades
yup
gotta go steal his smg dive for it
did we play all the maps today no
wait maybe i think we got all three
right now i think we did
evac and
combine
yeah
ow sounded pretty brutal
yeah we played evac the least which a
lot of people
usually pick actually
kind of shocked we're getting so much uh
hunted
um so people are asking about the perks
in the game there are a lot of similar
ones from past games they're you know
like silent footsteps is in here uh yeah
there's like the hard wired
they're sixth sense which will oops
which will uh kind of ping your map a
little bit if someone's close
um there is
one that kind of stops you from getting
detected by air stuff
like uav and what not yeah um
and there's hardwired which prevents
that anti-uav right or no it prevents
like any of your electronics from being
jammed which includes uav or
any score streaks you might have the
others are
over trying to clock which
um increases the speed of which you get
your special ability
there which i like especially for the
ones where you have like the sparrow has
a pretty long cooldown i think there's
one called anti-up that gives you 100
points already to your killstreak
yeah it's about 100. oh he pulled this
off at least
nice yeah you wanted me to do it off the
wall
crazy
all right we can try to just like
oh
the dream is dead worst game yet
i think is that about
it i only had time for that last game
all right
but anyway of course i go on on a lower
note
uh yeah anybody watching here just
pretend that last match didn't happen no
it wasn't terrible
you did much better than i did i'm glad
you rounded out the day oh wait we lost
that's why this is always confusing for
me because it's like well not confusing
i just want to see my score which i
guess oh 1.85 i was very hard on myself
wasn't as bad as i thought you always
are which is good i guess but i guess so
it helps you level faster that's for
sure yeah
so that was
call of duty black ops 3 on xbox one
debate has opened today for about four
days is eric tay playing it much better
than i was yeah just slightly it's fine
it might get extended i wouldn't be
surprised if you guys yeah and they'll
probably add that fourth map like they
did with ps4 and extend the
character classes you can expect two
more specialists if they do exactly what
they did on playstation you'll be able
to get reaper who's at 34 yeah and then
uh spectre who's at 40. both who are
very fun actually yeah so anyway anybody
who's watching thanks for stopping by
and you know stay tuned to gamespot for
future streams and maybe we'll see you
in the beta if i get back into it today
will you maybe we'll see maybe i don't
want to do the grind again
you will
anyway thanks a lot everyone see you
later
you